este grupo de amigos de León vino a
descubrir el barrio rojo de amsterdam Ya
llevan unos cuantos tragos y quién me va
a inflar la llanta
quién me hizo la broma
el fin de semana estará lleno de bromas
como muchos otros Joaquín está aquí para
celebrar su despedida de Soltero
realmente vinimos a beber ir de bar en
bar y divertirnos
hay discotecas ya veremos uno pensaría
que es tabú pero no es para nada
es muy divertido e invito a todo el
mundo a que venga amsterdam
pero ese no es el mensaje que quiere
transmitir la alcaldía de amsterdam
[Música]
en este vídeo en inglés a los turistas
que quieren venir a la capital holandesa
solo para vivir y salir de fiesta se les
hace una simple invitación
que se queden en casa una campaña
dirigida especialmente a los jóvenes
británicos
Irán que vienen de Manchester consideran
que el prejuicio es exagerado
no estoy aquí para provocar disturbios
como el resto del Reino Unido
sé que ha habido problemas en el pasado
con Los Hooligans pero eso es una
minoría
si uno observa la inmensa mayoría de los
británicos verá que no se comportan como
la gente piensa que lo hacen
esta campaña de la ciudad de amsterdam
forma parte de una iniciativa más amplia
para cambiar la imagen de la ciudad y
combatir las molestias de las que se
quejan los residentes desde el 25 de
mayo está prohibido fumar Cannabis en
las calles del barrio rojo una medida
que no desanimará a los clientes según
el propietario de un coffee Shop donde
se puede comprar marihuana y hachís
Si miran alrededor de este coffee Shop
pero aunque hay una gran diversidad de
gente hay abogados a estudiantes
mochileros también pero creo que la
imagen general que la gente tiene de los
coffee Shops es injusta
por su parte este nativo del centro de
la ciudad celebra la determinación de
las autoridades locales de frenar el
turismo de masas
Rubén ha visto como la zona se ha
transformado en los últimos años la
última estación de policía del distrito
tuvo que cerrar sus puertas en 2016 y
debido a la falta de personal hay muy
pocos controles en las calles del barrio
rojo
aquí viene sobre todo grupos grandes
normalmente de hombres que vienen solo
emborracharse fumarse un porro cantar
canciones y orinar en las puertas
si salgo y les digo por favor podrían
hacer menos ruido
suelen responder claro no sabíamos que
también era un barrio donde vivía gente
en un golpe a la vida cultural del
barrio Rubén va a tener que abandonar el
espacio donde se encuentra la galería de
arte en la que trabaja desde hace 15
años una cadena hotelera compró el
edificio
este viernes tendremos nuestra última
exposición en esta galería y después nos
van a sacar
es muy triste soy el único galerista que
queda por acá y me voy
Cuál es el plan
por no hablar del gran número de
viviendas que se han convertido en
alojamientos turísticos el otro blanco
de amsterdam es la prostitución las
autoridades locales se Proponen reubicar
a las trabajadoras sexuales en un centro
erótico situado A las afueras de la
ciudad Este propietario de un burdel que
alquila 24 ventanas se muestra cauteloso
ante el proyecto
en cierta manera no están del todo
equivocado si se tiene en cuenta que los
viernes y sábados por la noche entre las
ocho y las 12 hay exceso de turismo en
la zona y siempre hay muchísima gente
frente a las ventanas a las trabajadoras
sexuales no les gusta eso pero son solo
unas horas a la semana no son las 24
horas del día pero hay que pensárselo
dos veces antes de trasladar toda una
industria
las trabajadoras sexuales quieren que su
negocio funcione no solo atraer la
mirada curiosa de los turistas
en el barrio rojo el número de ventanas
ya descendido a la mitad desde 2007 este
antiguo burdel fue transformado
recientemente en un café
una transformación que refleja la
gentrificación que busca la ciudad
hay vuelos desde el Reino Unido que se
conocen como vuelos sexo drogas y
alcohol
el viernes por la noche ámsterdam
ni siquiera reservan hotel porque se van
de fiesta toda la noche y el sábado
vuelven a casa
la idea de esta política urbana es
atraer a otro tipo de turistas que
causen menos molestias y gasten más
dinero
el turismo sigue siendo un mercado
lucrativo para amsterdam la ciudad
recibió casi 19.000 millones de euros en
2019 con la cifra récord de 22 millones
de turistas es decir 25 veces más que el
número de habitantes